à ce qu'on sait et ce qui a été démontré
formellement c'est que c'est l'arrivée
d'individus du moyen-orient qui sont
arrivés avec leur agriculture
le gros débat c'était de savoir est ce
que c'est une diffusion juste des
technologies sans que des gens aient
bougé
ou alors est-ce que c'est des
agriculteurs qui sont arrivés avec leur
savoir faire et qui sont arrivés petit à
petit en europe et donc en comparant
l'adn des gens avant l'arrivée du
néolithique et après on a pu montrer que
effectivement c'est des gens qui
viennent pour l'europe du sud de
l'anatolie
il arrive en europe il s'installe et il
se mélange avec les chasseurs cueilleurs
sur place ce qui fait qu'à l'heure
actuelle on est des descendants des
mélanges d'eau - c2c deux poules génique
les chasseurs cueilleurs et les
agriculteurs donc on n'a pas inventé
nous nous je parle nous les français on
n'a pas inventé l'agriculture
elle nous a été amené par des immigrés
qui venait du moyen-orient en passant
par l'anatolie c'est bien ça oui tout à
fait tout à fait c'est venus du moyen
orient c'est des immigrés du
moyen-orient qui ont amené l'agriculture
en europe
[Musique]